on n'est absolument pas payé c'est un
documentaire en open télé monte dans la
tête des gens il m'a n'attendaient que
ça irresponsable ne touchez vous toucher
vous en toucher 0 c'est impossible je
vous jure sur la tête de mes gonds
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais passer à la mise au point on
voulait revenir avec vous sur cette
histoire de fou qui concerne nos
sondages twitter notre community manager
a remarqué depuis c'était avant-hier
restait mercredi qu'on pouvait plus
faire de sondages twitter et des hackers
trafic et de sondages afin de faire
pression sur l'émission c'est un truc de
fou c'est une histoire vraie jolie cette
semaine ces sondages auraient été
manipulés par des hackers
malintentionnés il ya eu des gens qui
ont fait des pressions et qui ont payé
apparemment un hacker pour hacker le nom
twitter de tmp est ce la première fois
que nos sondages sont sabotées un cyber
hackers nous a contactés nous indiquant
que des personnalités haut placées
aurait tenté à plusieurs reprises de
modifier nos résultats alors sondage de
tpm paix magouilles et les personnalités
puissantes et s'attelle vraiment de
faire pression sur l'émission pour as tu
un compte twitter il faut avant tout
récupérer le mot de passe et peut-être
avoir accès aux numéros de téléphone de
la personne mais pour votre cas votre
contre tritter c'est plus de la
manipulation de sondage c'est à dire
qu'en fait il ya des gens qui ont
utilisé une armée de compte twitter pour
manipuler votre sondage d'accord twitter
malheureusement donc vous n'avez pas de
deux paramètres qui vont vous empêcher
de falsifier ou de truquer un sondage
concrètement moi je suis robin des bois
mais je dispose d'une armée de comptes
twitter admettons 10000 compte twitter
vous sûreté pmp vous lancez un sondage
je regarde le résultat je peux très
facilement inversé la tendance du
sondage en fonction de combien de
personnes a voté chez vous pas bien sûr
en moyenne on a fait un petit calcul des
entre 20 et 50 mille personnes chez vous
qui va tous les sources et et à côté de
ça on voit sur certains sondages qui ont
été manipulés une explosion du nombre de
votes alors regardez on avait fait koh
lanta revient le mardi est ce qu'ils
veulent flinguer la marque regarder
avant hacking regardez regardez avant
hacking parce qu'on est à quai déjà on
revient le mardi est ce qu'ils veulent
flinguer la marque donc avant à khimki
résultat c'était ça où il ya 82 %
premier après regardez après voilà les
secondes mais ça devient c'est un cran
trois secondes ça s'est inversé et il ya
80% des gens qui disent non c'est fou
donc ça c'est c'est juste vos followers
en fait qui voilà qui votent et vous les
envoyer en même temps en fait voilà il
faut compte et donc ça fait ça voilà le
hacker utilise un logiciel ce qu'on
appelle un panel dans le milieu et avec
ce panel en une le commande il peut
ordonner à ses 10000 qu'on tousse et
20000 content d'aller voter non sur le
sondage de tp en tête nos équipes ont
reçu un message d'accord avec qui on
s'entend bien aussi tueur professionnel
qu'ils on a confirmé qu'il avait été
contacté et mandaté non par une personne
par les personnes pour changer les
résultats de nos sondages incroyable
voilà et pour hacker notre compte
twitter c'est il nous envoyer mais les
captures d'écran c'est incroyable ça
quand même un drap dans les bois c'est
un drame mais ça fait quand même partie
est omniprésente de notre vie en 2022
regarder traîne ce qui s'est passé avec
la côte sa campagne présidentielle on
parlait d'un million de budget par jour
dépensés sur les publicités facebook
aujourd'hui on peut regarder gagnante et
du monde notamment sur les femmes avec
zemmour qui était acheta qui a été
propulsé en tendance mais qui manquait
quand même organiquement de véritables
tweet c'est quelque chose de très
fréquents en fait je crois savoir de
nous ça vient ça se lit plus on peut pas
le dire là parce que ça vient d'un
pharmacien personne mais là c'est mon et
je l'emmenais sur un pain sur l'enquète
jeux wii
voilà et
on fait le plus tôt politique ou profs
et le plus tôt rivalité commerciale
c'est n'ont aucun des deux
[Musique]
couture même les fringues sont mes
pouces exemple chez opel son sale de
téléphone date de juin en glisse et des
gens qui rient au dix huitième degré
dans la salle au lieu d'encourager
quelqu'un qui se sort de la merde voilà
la bd questionner leurs qualités cette
critique et les gens qui ont envie de se
faire une situation ou sauvé au matin et
se battre des gens un peu comme ce petit
gros là non non non non on ne parle pas
aux ânes ça les instruit
sean may b à temps et tu fais donc alors
cyril tu revois ces propos a déjà je
suis désolé d'avoir gâché ce week end
j'ai entendu le début de l'émission
ouais c'est vrai tu as perdu au paddle
en plus oui
c'est pas voulu voilà on ne prévient pas
que je dis ce que je pense c'était mon
rêve c'est tu peux dire tout ce que tu
veux sur les gens tu peux dire qu'il n'a
pas de carrière qu'il est nul mais
continue de remplir par mtv un petit
gros
c'est pas possible alors voilà un
match où
carrefour on vous dit vite et grands aux
yeux bleus non c'était un petit gros
avec une moustache c'est une déception
[Applaudissements]
tu as été blessés franchement [ __ ]
mais je me suis fait je me suis fait
[ __ ] je me suis fait
sur le bo salle pour moi ce qui est sale
c'est pas toi c'est pas ta peau c'est
pas tes béton aline jours moi j'avais
pris comme ça donc ce que moi j'appelle
des choses sales c'est quand par exemple
de 8 à leur tunique [ __ ] trois fois
c'est pourquoi pas chier j'ai alors
c'est pas tout laisser tomber soir ses
trottoirs avala il est jaloux c'est pas
de jaloux rage et de mon port arrête tu
peux pas toi faire le très vite même
[Rires]
c'est pareil
fred 24 semaines tu le ferais comme les
barnard au palace monde équestre venir
[Applaudissements]
pour jouer un match de premier league il
est bien sûr avec west ham et regarder
est-ce qu'il fallait le laisser jouer et
regarder son arrivée sur le terrain qui
a été un petit peu mouvementée
on est obligé de s'interroger sur la
titularisation de coeur de l'humain ce
soir a été le juge c'est jouer bien sûr
mais il n'y a aucun rapport entre le
geste horrible qu'il a fait et
l'exercice de sa profession c'est
complètement dissociés il a une amende
il joue d'ailleurs son entraîneur a dit
qu'il était indispensable
je ne vois pas pourquoi on l'empêcherait
d'exercer son métier cyril qui utilisent
mac je peux juste pas les sanctions
qu'il a imaginé ce qu'il a eu c'est la
vue de des bois avec sa femme il ya des
sanctions c'est laurette il n'aurait pas
joué leur âge ou la ville attend bien
sûr
avec sur des gens qui eux pratiquent et
les violences conjugales et qui joue
encore alors oui oui dans les scieries
giuly bien oui moi c'était juste sa
comparaison avec un être humain pour moi
c'est un être vivant tu veux pas d'un
être vivant si ça fait du mal ça doit
être le même sens le sens qu'elle sera
neutre que moi donc c'est une bonne
c'est une bonne question c'est oui le
rallye oui moi je trouve qu'il s'agit de
montrer l'exemple parce qu'en fait le
droit des animaux c'est quelque chose
qui est encore trop peu méprisé par le
droit alors on commence en angleterre et
une loi en mai 2021 qui s'est intéressé
à la maltraitance des animaux en france
aussi on ne considère que les animaux
comme des objets parce qu'on vient déjà
meublé aujourd'hui que ce sont des êtres
doués de sensibilité et c'est essentiel
que le débat public prennent fait et
cause dans cette lutte contre la
maltraitance des animaux et il fallait
effectivement pas le laisser jouer donc
moi pardon mais je trouve que tu es
d'une indulgence ville mais vraiment
cessé je sais pas je suis choqué trois
cent mille euros ok c'est la loi mais
par non moi il ya une histoire de
moralité et moi chez west ham je ne mets
pas sur le terrain je le vire en fait je
ne dégage alors peut-être qu'à une
rupture conventionnelle peut-être qu'il
ya des indemnités prendra un gros chèque
mais je veux plus en entendre parler en
fait je veux plus le voir sur ma pelouse
parce que moi en tant dirigeants je veux
pas que ce mec-là qui a fait du mal à ce
chat là il peut faire du mal à n'importe
qui et c'est pas bien et donc qu'ils
dégagent le plus beau de parler des
changes me maquille le prêt non plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si les conditions de détention en prison
sont souvent désastreuses certains
détenus dits médiatique bénéficierait de
cellules réservées on les appelle
quartier pour personnes vulnérables ou
quartier vip des zones où les conditions
de détention sont un peu meilleures et
où les détenus ont le privilège d'être
seul dans leur cellule certains estiment
qu'il est normal de les protéger
d'autres pensent qu'il ne mérite pas
plus que d'autres ce traitement de
faveur alors là et claude guéant balkany
trouvez vous normal qu'il existe des
quartiers vip en prison d'abord ça
n'existe pas dû vérifier en prison ça
l'était pas il ya qu'à la santé qui a eu
le mot vip qui a tous en prison c'est
comme si c'était la rue c'est à dire tu
es dans la rue c'est à dire c'est du
business et chante quelque chose pour
quelque chose quelque chose mais ce
n'est bien pis ça n'existe pas moi je
suis là quimby qui a dû vip en prison
bon allez j alors qu'on a vu c'est pas
vrai les jeunes te dire si toutes les
chez lui ça existe toutes les cellules
alors tu me le vip maintenance torrent
cd traduit ça existe toujours c'est bah
oui ça va oui c'est comme ça mais dans
toutes les prisons c'est comme ça olive
olive toi tu comprends pas qu'ils aient
des quartiers privilégiés en prison mais
carrément pas mais je pense qu'on prend
un peu le problème à l'envers d'ailleurs
et si on reprenait le problème je pense
qu'à des pancartes qu'ils finiraient par
se tourner quel des gens qu'ils soient
isolés parce que c'est des politiques ou
ceci cela à la rigueur ça je pense que
ça peut se comprendre par contre quand
on voit l'état des cellules 9 mètres
carrés je pense à la même formule 1 les
chambres d'hôtel ils sont mais là
quand je vois des gens qui arrivent à
sourire parce que tu fais le clown sur
les plateaux télé et qu'on entraîne peu
médiatisé aujourd'hui est presque que tu
vas finir en héros moi sincèrement ça me
retourne le ventre parce que il faut que
tous les citoyens soient conscients que
tu as pris de l'argent dans les poches
de tout le monde en fait par rapport à
ce que tu as fait et ça je trouve ça
inadmissible sincèrement
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a pas juste un oui mais je me
sens beaucoup parler alors qu'on est en
train de faire toi là ces jeunes gens et
c'est ce que je pense de la star sait
même pas de quoi tu parles
limousine la seule différence c'est que
toi tu va [ __ ] le bordel dehors dans
la rue pour arrêter des gens de
travailler les ferrari
mercedes et une guitare s'est parlé on
s'est parlé aux jeunes
espoirs parler j'avais fait mes armes et
tu ne bois pas avec moi laisse moi
parler je te le dis qu'il est ce moi pas
mais t'es qui toi et toi t'étais qui toi
mais dont il n'est ni tout à huit ans de
prison
à la vie ni ses marques en wallonie des
choses légalement bah oui pourquoi
légalement mais pourquoi légalement mais
kalou boulanger ils encaissent des
espèces
enquête ces mesures mais d'une mesure
pourquoi alors c'est pareil tu me lis a
dû des mesures mais c'est pas un peu
d'espacé truc de 183 millions d'euros si
tu veux il ya un peu une
fait beaucoup de manière qui pose la
question est ce que tu sais comment est
ce que tu sais aussi qu'on est riche
c'est pas pareil comment c'est qu'on ait
eue je sais que tu le sais non alors je
vais t'expliquer moi je suis jamais mon
coeur mais ça ne suffit pas celle à bp
vous voulez parler de cet appel à l'aide
de la famille pélissard depuis qu'ils
ont débarqué dans l'émission familles
nombreuses la vie en xxl j'adore cette
émission vraiment ils sont devenus de
véritables stars chaque jour amandine
maman de huit enfants partage son
quotidien sur les réseaux avec toute sa
famille devant des centaines de milliers
d'abonnés
le problème cette exposition a attisé
les jalousies la haine la famille s'y
retrouver menacé de mort avec des
lettres anonymes envoyées à leur
domicile de la mère amandine très
inquiète pour ses enfants a d'ailleurs
essayé d'avertir plusieurs fois la
police en vain si aujourd'hui elle prend
la parole à travers les réseaux c'est
pour protéger sa famille d'un éventuel
drame ce soir amandine pellissier a
décidé de tirer la sonnette d'alarmé
dans tpm cette fois les stars la famille
pélissard de l'émission et c'est vrai
que depuis quelques jours c'est devenu
un cauchemar et vous avez reçu je vais
lire un là il ya quinze jours il avait
reçu une lettre dans votre boîte dans
laquelle on insulte votre famille et
vous même alors j'ai le contenu de la
lettre
espèce de saloperies
ta gueule botoxée tu ressembles à ce que
tu es voilà aussi la démocratie
maintenant envie de dire parce que tu es
une honte pour les familles nombreuses
c'est alors si il ya des franchement
regardez regardez là c'est vraiment
voilà c'est à vomir de ça à vomir après
cette première lettre on a voulu porter
plainte mais la police a refusé cette
plainte et nous a octroyé courante
d'accord pensant que ce n'était pas
suffisant s'était passé lourd en fait
pour se justifier par une plainte
simplement une main courante au kazoo il
se passerait quelque chose et si on
recevait une deuxième lettre on pouvait
la déposer plainte ce serait légitime
alors une semaine plus tard vous recevez
une deuxième lettre cette fois-ci
adresser à votre mari alexandre je
m'adresse à vous alexandre pélissard
quand vous pouvez supporter la vie avec
votre on va voir voilà deux pays tiers
de femmes amandine en ce moment elle est
à paris et h et chaque fois que votre
ennemi [ __ ] on vous trompe nous avons
des preuves et photos qui seront mis sur
instagram nous avons eu son père
biologique et les mentions ce qui leur
dit sur sa vie comme quoi elle a été
abusée c'est faux soyez indulgents
alexandre vous êtes un bon bah ça à
faire la une des journaux bon courage
foncez vous avez déterminé que ça ne
venait pas de loin
vient très certainement de quelqu'un de
là où vous habitez qui vous connaît bien
c'est ça qui fait encore plus peur bien
sûr vous avez une idée la première
enveloppe effectivement le code
le code le code 33 et le code du centre
distribution est plus proche de notre
domicile donc effectivement en tout cas
la première enveloppe penser qu'elle a
pas été posté
tf1 prend cette affaire très au sérieux
puisque dans l'après midi tf1 a tenu à
réagir géré téléspectateurs depuis
plusieurs semaines les femmes y sont
régulièrement attaqués sur les réseaux
sociaux n'y a pas que vous un sur les
réseaux il ya toutes les raisons on en
prend tous pour notre grade nous tenons
à rappeler que si fameux nombreuses la
vie en xxl et une émission que nous
aimons tous commente est il important de
le faire dans le respect d'autrui les
insultes menaces et messages haineux à
l'égard des familles n'ont pas lieu
d'être condamnons fermement ce genre de
comportement et recommandons famille de
porter plainte merci c'est fou qu'il
quittait le n sur ce programme ça prend
des proportions
exponentielles koala la haine la rage
est souvent enfin moi de ce que je vois
en tout cas ça vient beaucoup de pas de
jeunes pas d'adolescent mais deux femmes
nous sommes le femmes de mon âge plus
âgées même si c'est celle là les pierres
je pense que les enfants sont beaucoup
plus intelligents que les adultes
parfois parce que en fait à l'école les
gamins entre eux on est très attentif de
saison en saison on fait très attention
justement à ce qui se passe on
communique avec les quelques
établissements avec qui voilà on a
renforcé mans en très bons termes par
rapport à ça et non méfier elles sont
des copines parce qu'elle s'appelle
l'ena lina louna et mes garçons pareil
et pas parce qu'ils passent à la télé
c'est ça les parents en fait qui après
la sortie de l'école viennent vous
encore une fois le problème c'est pas
les enfants assez les êtres vivants qui
paye pas savoir mais si ça se trouve les
gens pensent comme ça alors vous avez
étudié pour cette émission monde en aura
toujours des méchants on n'est
absolument pas payé c'est un
documentaire en épingle pour alimenter
un sermon talent dans la tête des gens
il m'a n'attendais que ça irait sans ça
le touche et vous toucher 0 on touche 0
arnaque c'est impossible je vous jure
sur la tête de mes gosses c'est à dire
sur la torah
c'est incroyable produits les femmes
production des f1 production qui il voue
pennant statut de documentaires mais en
fait renforcée pour une mission c'est
l'émission la plus rentable du fait d un
statut et la télé réel voulait pas faire
de la télé sur ses vitres non mais c'est
incroyable il ya beaucoup moins de
menace sinon mais on ne croit pas en
plus quand on me choquera pas à toucher
même pas une indemnité non touché du
tout on n'est pas rémunéré c'est un
documentaire alors quand on a des
déplacements
on avait besoin de la production bien
sûr là ça prend en charge mais c'est
légitime afin bien sûr voilà mais c'est
tout alors je vous dit tout - dean il ya
quelqu'un de tf1
je m'envoie attestation de tournage
jours de présence de l'équipe tournage
trois jours un des mythes et 100 euros x
3 jours égale 300 euros signature de
madame pp amandine pélissard bon pour
accord donc ça c'est un défraiement
c'est un défraiement pour les pour les
frais de tournage fait d'accord voilà
d'accord dont a besoin quand on
donc ça veut dire que c'est vrai parce
que si on m'envoie ça ah oui ça veut
bien dire qu'ils ne sont pas payés
belle affaire vient entacher le
programme
un des futurs candidats de l'émission
françois un pompier de 38 ans est
entendu dans une affaire pour homicide
involontaire comme le révèle le canard
enchaîné ce candidat qui ait atta
pompiers de 38 ans
était donc mis en examen pour homicide
involontaire sur des faits qu'il remonte
au 10 août 2016 ou lors d'une
intervention dans dans l'hérault sur
dans une forêt de dans les hauteurs de
gabian en fait dès des pompiers ont
été grièvement blessées et un pompier un
jeune pompier de 24 ans est mort et les
familles et les syndicats donc on
lançait une procédure
contre des hauts gradés et notamment
françois qui qui qui qui voit là alors
je vous dis rliss l'histoire c'est quoi
ces histoires on monte à 2016 coït lors
d'un incendie de forêt françois descamps
est accusé d'avoir donné à la troupe des
ordres inadaptée parfois contradictoires
et fournit une information suivent
insuffisante et des matériels obsolètes
voilà vingt membres sur sept membres
c'est ça dont affaire l'un se dit avait
causé la mort d'un pompier de 24 ans et
sept pompiers avaient été mis en examen
pour homicides involontaires et
blessures involontaires
alors vous êtes on était que m ludovic
par avocat du candidat milan ce qu'est
ce que vous répondez aux gens qui disent
qu'il doit qui n'aurait pas dû être dans
l'émission je trouve que déjà c'est
commencer par là fait de dire ça il faut
commencer par le début et je vous
remercie d'avoir rappelé les faits tels
que vous en avez connaissance parce que
je trouve que finalement ça reflète bien
ce dossier hier soir avant de me coucher
j'apprends par françois que ça y est ses
sorties alors qu'est-ce qui est sorti
que il est mis en examen dont acte c'est
la vérité je peux pas dire le contraire
alors mise en examen d'un candidat pour
homicide involontaire dans la nouvelle
saison de koh lanta fallait-il le coupé
au montage depuis le dernier dit oui oui
oui parce que m moi je vais vous le dire
très franchement votre client il a menti
au moins par omission ce qui s'est passé
c'est que la production ne pouvait pas
savoir même rencontres en sept personnes
et que son identité qu'il était mis en
examen parce que quand les noms ont été
révélés seul le nom du responsable des
pompiers a été publié lui françois way
n'a pas été cité mais quand il est
arrivé au casting de koh lanta il était
mis en examen il aura pas d' il a montré
le casier judiciaire honnêtement m il
aurait dû dire je suis mis en examen il
ne pouvait pas participer savez ce que
c'est que d'être mis en examen est il
non sans s'être mis en examen c'est être
présumé 800 voilà le problème dans ce
dossier c'est qu'en fait aujourd'hui il
ya une espèce de tribunal médiatique qui
essaye de se substituer à la justice le
problème du tribunal médiatique c'est à
dire le tribunal auquel on siège de tous
à cette table et en france il n'a pas de
régler notamment la rive de la
présomption d'innocence il ne la connaît
pas pourquoi françois descamps il est
aujourd'hui mis en cause dans ce dossier
parce qu'il était le responsable de la
formation et ça et qu'on a mis en cause
toute la chaîne sa part des plus hauts
gradés le responsable de la formation
slovaque aux sables du matériel ça le
responsable opérationnel
pourquoi n'at-il pas dit au moment de
koh lanta je suis mis en examen la
sélection d'aller dans une émission
comme celle là on est en mis en examen
le jugement aura peut-être lieu cette
année mais la voilà la réponse si vous
me demandez si en disant ça ils auraient
pu finalement expliqué à la production
qui devait bénéficier de la présomption
d'innocence et qui faisait les missions
dans ces six mois ça n'aurait jamais
parce que c'est sérieux c'est de l'eau
c'est la première vous dire quelque
chose ça fait moins de 24 heures que
c'est sorti et je suis chez cyril
hanouna en train de parler de ce dossier
avec un buzz comme celui-là mais
attendent c'est vraiment que s'il avait
dit ça à la production on lui aurait dit
on va vous accorder le bénéfice du doute
mais voilà
ils auraient pu l'arrêter ce n'est pas
la majorité de cette consiste à vous
dire monsieur qu' il ne l'a pas dit
parce qu'on ne lui a pas posé la
question aux missions m mensonge par
omission ou non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]